everyone happy day today's the day the
decals out correct yeah yes so I thought
I'd wear a Deadpool t-shirt Matt thank
you for getting me into Deadpool welcome
I kind of I judged you
I said ma'am well showing you guys the
trailers and stuff yeah I gotta money by
me but I didn't actually get it you know
the now you get it he's the anti
superhero either way if you guys see
Deadpool go check it out
Matt and I both did interview did you
edit any of your interview out what
channel really small snippet I think I
like 30 seconds long I love the whole
thing in there but I left I'd edited out
the football party what's after
Washington I'm gone oh no guys a feet
turn right onto West Washington
Boulevard and then you're gonna turn
left on CSC where colonial yeah it's
right here
yes really made me it's really mad at me
because I'm making Southwest shot right
now is your wall set to happen am i late
- Wasatch Avenue in six hundred feet
turn left onto West Washington Boulevard
you want to turn left if you can okay
let's write down the corner it's right
there on the corner see it you turn the
color yellow just testin asian with the
other right yeah yeah I'm having some
friends come over tonight and be our
part well we gonna Park it across we'll
just run over on the street I want to
make a heart cake for my friends for
Valentine's Day I baked an emoji cake so
this is just gonna be a vlog baking okay
I get some adidas I where am i with my
camera
keep it out think I had it on I think
can I not get it Irina Jenna you gone
not your whip is nice Street kids are
that weirdo and legally look at you just
helping us carry the baked goods across
the street very Jenna wanted raspberry
Matt wanted strawberry so Jenna was
soaked on it and she won't she let not
have this robbery listen to John Matt
where we going now we were going to say
factory this is my jam whoa shut them
down and then open up clearance of six
four oh god I'm scared for you I'm gonna
puke the cakes I love it when you call
me big papa
God dude we've been really rolling up
you know what you guys havin I need some
like caffeine or sugar what I don't know
what you guys been drinking today I'm
dancin big you say I get you biggie can
it's just zoomx c'mon I was like yes
honestly just what I needed
oh yeah we always know purple you wanted
to stop
what's concerned strawberry icing lives
in the back seat is going to melt that's
actually really good concern better go
move it and move it'll be fine we're not
we're funny yeah I'm excited make the
gig I hope it's good pain you're so fat
yeah I wanted to go and stop in a store
to look at something and that was like
we gotta get home and bake the gank
meanwhile your cheesecake
yeah these steps are really fit this
level-
yeah I saw what that icing isn't leaked
all over the leather how much oh my god
emigrated person went oh oh my god I'm
so sorry
oh shut off don't ya don't open the car
Flo
come on we got we got cleaning this up
yeah man it is let's go I just so I'll
clean it up I wanna see look I clean
just well fine we're good yeah we're
good
take it off Jimmy disgusting look at
this stuff he didn't eat wouldn't you
think Michael
that was incredible Thank You Manny you
took all of your items outside and you
relief in your mouth all of your items
baby we need to put on your Valentine
sweater I gotta get a couple pictures of
it wha we're waiting for some of our
groceries to be delivered so we can make
this cake it's gonna be delicious
I'm extremely excited because I think
it's gonna be a very successful cake and
I'm proud I'm proud let's do it okay I'm
taking you ties away guys mom well
making the cake now many would suppose
we go making two of these he's making a
big cake making a big fight you wanna
get outside two cups of water
how I actually just use the mixer for
this cuz I've got a mixer I saw her use
it yeah and it will you be hi Matthew
I actually do like baking I'm just not
good at kind of the water whoa
okay now we need a whole cup of oil we
also need now so we need 1/2 cup 1/2 cup
humming a mess for me
digital noses go so fast
great briefs these Hartman's just
luckiest shoes
I don't want sick whoa don't suck Turks
up about the filling Oh wish it was
raspberry don't dogs cute cakes in the
oven
he'll sue us
and
how was it good I got a smell beat some
looting just effective therapies let's
show you the middle so since you guys
were gone we've prepped the cake and
there's also Twinkies a lot more you
like I'm sorry I just tried it it was
incredible
oh god wait wait what was the last one
the magic a turned out well cake yeah I
think you might I made um haven't posted
it yet but I made cupcakes of Mady space
ricotta and frosting everybody doubted
sugar and everything
a frosting magician I was terrible Oh
rats
I can't wait for you guys to see the
video all right guys thanks for watching
today's video
listen this is Maddie going to sleep
mask human going hey Jen iguana please
see yeah it's maybe potentially tomorrow
we'll see fight wild party last night
guys
now we're off to go for a hike and I
have a sort of really bad headache
actually not sort of a hallway
yeah alright so for Ike you know go for
a walk Maddie ready to go all pretty of
it that hike was it up here that the dog
hi Chloe I think it was up a little bit
okay this is it anymore
walking the dog
but there's another one over here that's
like a little dog trail that I think
takes us to somewhere else
I need the vlog I need the vlog look at
Geodude dog duty Matt with Matt yeah I
heard he can't he's so excited to be
outside he's like you left me inside all
day today he only got a little walk
yesterday so we were just discussing the
struggles of having a dog at this point
when I first got it was like a hoses
hook girls I got only clean cups crap
like you know what at this point I he's
I've carried him across the room and
caught poo - falling out of his butt
I've caught puke she's coming out of his
mouth when I'm in bed so it doesn't puke
all over me are my sheets that's love
that's true love you know come at you
love he Shh the bag of poop you're going
to the DMX or what's up I don't think
you guys know where you're going you
know uh no there is no you look use your
sign did you see the sign did it open up
your eyes did you see it there we go oh
you good buddy good success today
here's the problem
I don't know what a joke oh there's a
scientist really yeah but I think this
actually might take us right back where
we went
let's see where this takes us honey the
Bunsen
and we're on an adventure I think we
should get another dog look that's me
right now
he isn't this about oh man we were
really out there we've never done this
hike before it's uh we where did you say
we're going I don't think we're on the
right trail we're going to Malta mala do
Mordor board or winnable door Oh
Mordor like another like multiple doors
like Dumbledore like Harry Potter let's
not forget we have to go back oh there's
no dog on this woman it wasn't a dog on
the last time yeah but one by one
oh no on tape reverses but if it's not a
dog trail they will say no dogs they
will have a sign here that says no
dollars right we show that it has four
dogs dogs Donna the sign said 2.1 miles
to Will Rogers yeah now we have one
point one miles left so we went one
point well let me tell you what we went
we went one point three six miles from
here I guess
yesterday yes your girls who we do I'm
keeping my opinions to myself yeah what
do you think I don't want to be the
damper I think turning around would be a
good idea solely because this entire
trail was downhill yep and I don't think
it's been especially since they have a
dog you don't have to convince me to
turn around I was ready to turn around
point five miles ago same cool but I
don't be that guy well go we'll do this
another day
it's not even I mean we keep going oh my
god I gotta get ready go even snowball
whoa I just wanted to start filming is I
think daddy's gonna try to grab this big
stick Jos gonna get taken there's
nothing in this come on let's go Madi oh
you didn't even want the stick thought
for sure you would let's go also with
this hike no doctor I need cards instead
happy Valentine's dude a couple of
always welcomes me on something real--
me is it from me feel I don't know I
don't know Maddy Oh could you not be
here I don't know what's your Wikipedia
say Matt look at our dirty little doggy
Maggie women to sail off the leather
Matt will be very mad and they'll make
us get rid of you we're gonna go get
lunch no guys yeah where should we go
kid I think we should do the BP Maddie
look at you
we've been here for a little while
waiting from the food going to a party
tonight and very excited about it it's
at a castle it's a it's an actual castle
hold out I feel bad can thing about it
being cold but it's I'm chill
look I wanna take off your coat and put
it on my body
he wants to play with everybody the logs
my dog steam kidding I'm gonna take his
cold you know I'm not good to bathe your
dog all the time but he pees on itself
and it's like you disgusting any big
cool I'm Alice I'm cold
yours is that you're absolutely like I'm
actually quite disgusted with your body
right now these are the boys again you
having a good time you know you got
cracking on Chinese would sit in the top
right I might as well
mom doesn't matter
alright thanks for watching this vlog
happy Valentine's Day this is a vlog
over the course of a couple of days do
you guys prefer or vlogs sort of just
kind of like one day or do you prefer
longer vlogs consisting of a couple of
days because I like posting videos but I
don't know posting videos every day is
something you guys like what do you guys
like I'll tell you what I like
not this computer this computer has
caused me so much hassle I think you
guys might remember what I told you that
my hard drive crash lost everything I've
had two hard drives go bad on this and
two internal drives to go bad and also I
had a hard drive connected to it that
failed as well the other day I finally
like lost my mind
trying to edit a video it was taking so
long I was like I could have ended six
videos in the time that it took me to
edit this one so I'm gonna go edit over
there on Jenna's computer and I finally
ordered a Mac Pro I was like your job
Justine is editing video and if you
can't do your job properly on your
computer that's not good well I'm
excited about that so I'll probably have
a tech Tuesday it might not be out for
Tuesday so I hope you like a tech
whenever not sure I just woke up so I'm
gonna edit this video and drink my
coffee and carry on with the day so I
hope you guys are doing well and I'll
see you when I see you bye bye
cool I just started okay close I've done
yet
what is the cake almost ready alright oh
this is all better now
you